across the whole of the united kingdom
people are engaged in a huge
joint effort to put the coronavirus back
in its box
throughout this pandemic the government
has done whatever
it takes to protect lives and
livelihoods in england
scotland wales and northern ireland
we've put in place
an unprecedented package of economic
support protecting the wages
and jobs of millions of people we've
built
the largest testing capacity in europe
with 32 million tests conducted so far
and over half a million tests now
available every day
across the uk we've ensured as we head
into the winter
that the nhs has at its disposal over 30
000 ventilators
and billions of items of personal
protective equipment
most of it now manufactured here
in the uk across the whole of the uk we
have a
shared goal to suppress the virus
ensure the nhs is not overwhelmed
and in doing so to save lives the uk
government and the devolved
administrations are working together
on a joint approach to the christmas
period because all of us want to ensure
families
can come together wherever they live
the challenges we face are significant
across the uk the average number of new
cases each day is now
22 398. that's up from
9716 a month earlier
there are now 12 320 patients in
hospital
up from 2602 a month earlier
1142 patients are now
in mechanical ventilation that
mechanical ventilation beds
up from 369 a month earlier
and sadly 492 deaths were reported
yesterday
and the weekly average number of deaths
each day
is now 295 up from 53
a month earlier so that's why a new
restrictions are in place
in each part of the uk and in england
from today we're once again asking you
to stay at home as i explained on
saturday
you can only leave home for specific
reasons for
work if you can't work from home for
education
and for essential activities and
emergencies
the full rules all the details are
available at
gov dot uk forward slash coronavirus
and on the nhs kovid 19 apps and
please log on to see what you can and
can't do i know
how tough this is for staff in
the nhs and care homes who are facing a
tough winter on the front line for
for families who can't meet in the the
way that they
would want to for businesses forced to
shut just as
you're getting back on your feet i know
that many of you are anxious
weary and quite frankly fed up with the
very mention
of this virus but i want to assure you
this is not
a repeat of the spring schools
universities and nurseries
are all staying open and these measures
though they are tough
are time limited the advice i've
received suggests that four weeks is
enough
for these measures to make a real impact
so
these rules will expire and on the 2nd
of december
we plan to move back to a tiered
approach
there is light at the end of the tunnel
we have better treatments and techniques
to take
to take care of those in hospital thanks
largely to the ingenuity
of british scientists rapid testing is
being rolled out
on a massive scale with city-wide
testing starting
tomorrow in liverpool and i'm hugely
grateful to the people of liverpool for
their participation
in this pilot i hope that by working
together
we can get that great city on top of the
virus
more broadly there is also the very real
chance
of safe and effective vaccines
so taking those things together
these scientific advances can show us
the way ahead
and in the meantime this government will
continue to support people
affected by these new restrictions
as you know we've protected almost 10
million jobs through furlough
and as the chancellor announced earlier
today we're now extending the scheme
through to march we're also extending
our support
for the self-employed so that the next
payment increases
to 80 percent of average products
uh profits uh we're providing cash
grants
for businesses who are closed worth more
than one billion pounds
every month we're giving 1.1 billion
pounds
to local authorities in england to
support businesses
and a further two billion pounds of
funding is guaranteed for scotland
wales and northern ireland
as we face these challenges together we
must look after
those most in need as of september we've
helped over twenty nine thousand rough
sleepers
off the streets two thirds of whom are
now
in settled accommodation today we're
announcing a further
15 million pounds and to help councils
offer safe accommodation
for people who are sleeping rough or at
risk of becoming
homeless this program will help areas
that need additional support
most during the restrictions and
throughout the winter these are
difficult
times and while it pains me
to have to ask once again for
so many to give up so much
i know that together we can get through
this
so please for the next four weeks
stay at home protect the nhs
and save lives